[Music]
whatever whatever so what's really cool
is we have the prototype of the shady
agents game and we only have a few days
left to the Kickstarter so make sure you
go check that out there's gonna be a
link in the description below we're
actually really really proud of this
game this is the first time after
playing years and years of other
people's games where we've been able to
create our own game and it has every one
of our staff cruise bases on there so a
little bit of piece of all of us is in
this game and I think you guys are
really really gonna like it and also
there's a bunch of challenges on the
Kickstarter so make sure you go do that
because if you unlock those challenges
we're gonna add really funny cards into
it and a bunch of mystery items into it
so that's the incentive so go check that
out and when you pledged to the
Kickstarter what you're actually doing
is securing your copy of the game so
you'll get it before anyone else gets it
and there's a bunch of exclusive stuff
that will never be available afterwards
yeah the game we're actually gonna play
the game yeah okay so yeah so for those
of you that don't know um we also play
games if you're like wait wait you guys
only do neut no we play games you see
it's not just getting part of the same
face this face is on just kidding party
on just couldn't you know nobody go
check it out sure exactly do hard news
all right
hard news that are breaking news on the
moment we're the first on scene right
here okay so I'm gonna take the game
away I'm super excited because we
haven't played with David yet so I can't
wait to see what his lying face or true
face looks like all right so all of you
guys please look at your card and see
what team you're on are you a good guy
which will be blue team are you a bad
guy which is the red team so we'll never
reveal what that role is all right
should we show them or no yeah we can do
it one by one no we do it one by one
without everyone else see your eyes
Chloe your eye three two one badda Bing
Bing BAM okay I'm done I'm
okay my turn ready but a ping ping Bao
Bao okay done
technically dalla just close your eyes
and put it up okay ready what is it okay
three two one okay everyone subscribe to
David's old comedy yeah that [ __ ] was
gonna take whatever okay there you're
smarter than you look
alright so red means liar and blue means
truther yes that's what I said okay so
since David hasn't played I'm gonna have
him just watch everyone else plays so
German I have you started okay so this
game consists of two round where two
round we're entering the first round and
in this first round bar I mean boy I
love you so much
Joe can make one of three moves he can
interrogate where he asks a question he
can peek at anyone elses card to see
what team they're on or lastly he can
make a move and making a move means
he'll deliver or hurt or hurt or a guard
or a heal card you essentially want to
heal people on your team and you want to
hurt people that are not on your team
I'm gonna give up one of these cards to
peek at my neighbor to see if there is a
friend or a fault so in order to do that
he has to sacrifice one of those cards
what do I want to do okay yeah let me
see your shits with the book already huh
oh okay now on to the Tiffany yeah so
his turn is over Tiffany you're next
alright make those three moves peak
interrogate or make a move I want to
ask a question oh you could just leave
it in the front hey I don't need to put
in there look we got envelopes since
we're so far away okay I'm asking a
question and the question is um what's
your secret weakness oh boy
is the secret weight weakness my secret
weakness is [ __ ] that's a blue card
right there man damn blue team and this
is secret weakness oh wait whoa what's
your secret weakness Jesse what's your
secret weak my secret weakness yeah um
my secret weakness then would have to be
cute furry little puppies oh that's it
that's the secret I mean did I have ever
told you guys that I was weak what about
that did you guys know that before you
talk about it
wait really all right fine I'll give you
another secret we this is hard and
what's the secret weakness um grandma's
chewing without dentures on another
secret weakness is a fear of public
speaking oh oh is that not a secret
either we're movin on that's what I'm
stickin with that okay our puppies is
yours yes okay my secret weakness is my
butthole so anytime someone gets really
close I could be like in the most raging
mood and I want about to [ __ ] someone up
and as soon as that guy gets on his
knees and just licks my butthole my
bellybutton just goes inside out and I'm
like oh and he could beat me up I don't
know if I ever so you turn in a
jellyfish yeah I put it I turn into
inside out laundry day
super relatable yeah you just gave out
your [ __ ] secrets man if someone's
gonna [ __ ] you up and they've been
targeting you and they're gonna get
there they don't have to train their
fists they just got to train their
tongue train that song yeah yeah all
right David your turn
what's your secret weakness this is a
deep question it is are you ready to
tell us if this is a secret yeah in my
mind I'm guessing like it's stuff that
people wouldn't really expect so I guess
like my secret weakness would be like I
kind of found out this about myself
while I was dating Muriel it's actually
that I actually don't like open and
public affection mmm no it's not so much
that it's just like kind of like when
you're like really affectionate with
somebody you kind of like let yourself
be a little vulnerable and I don't like
that [ __ ]
Oh like it doesn't even matter if it's
in public it's just you could be even
with the person that you're with like I
don't like it so much sometimes and
sometimes you just want to like push
them away that's my like maybe I guess
that's something that I found out when I
was with Muriel that would be my secret
weakness it's like I don't like lucky
ass Mary hold on cuz Joan knows David's
part wait why is that lucky marital
David story mmm-mmm-mmm my secret I have
a lot
can you guess one of yours go ahead go
ahead it's on not anymore
Oh oh [ __ ] I'm responsible now okay that
means Jessa is helping them out yes
because whenever I get Amazon package
she goes what's that yeah and I say look
I need this for this she's like you know
sometimes like an Amazon package comes
to the house and it's not even mine and
I open it why because because because I
automatically assume it's mine I know
you kind of set it up well you gave me
time to think so my secret we I have a
lot of I have a lot of secret weaknesses
but my biggest secret with weakness is
when I put my mind to something I do it
but sometimes my mind is not always in a
good place to do it
but if it's like I want it I'm gonna
do it I'm on a [ __ ] pack of Ding
Dongs i'ma get it but we were [ __ ]
grocery shopping the other day to get
some like smoothie produce like [ __ ]
straight-up lettuce and all that because
we wanted to be healthy right and for
some [ __ ] odd reason there's a
hostess stand in the middle of the
produce section where it should it
should not be there and I said ding
dongs and it just was like Twinkies and
then we're like well if you want to
indulge then I guess it's okay because
we can both indulge so we grab that but
we went to go get some frozen things
like a frozen burrito but there was a
frozen ding dong and I had to get that
the frozen burrito is not any more
healthier than the ding dong the juice
section and they had ding dong juice by
the way have you had ding dong ice cream
no it's [ __ ] well well played he
didn't even answer that question uh
Steve that ding dong bitten it's your
turn
you can peek interrogate or make them up
okay I'm going to I'm gonna make a
question can I get a question yeah first
all [ __ ] I gotta get my car do I do I
put it in the middle because we're all
in separate tables tell us about someone
you dated but it didn't work out okay so
when I dated but it didn't work out um
tell us about someone I dated then it
didn't work out why didn't it work out I
think that's juicy tell us check some
[ __ ] okay uh so after high school I went
into a JC I started dating this guy and
he was cool and all like he had a really
cool car
he had a 65 Mustang and I was like oh
he's awesome he's like this rock dude
longer hair but it didn't work out
because he was a lot shorter than me
like blue jet that was another reason
because he was just shorter than me
otherwise you would be having his goodra
now huh otherwise you had his kid right
now
now I don't water huh I don't know about
that the man next to you no uh no he was
a lot shorter than part was he at your
bellybutton level no that's like that's
like a little person yeah see the
corrector ball right yeah exactly
[ __ ] you mean was he imagined or was
he like like a jockey to ride horses it
a major it smaller than a jockey that
right all right rides horses yeah okay
all right um I'm gonna go a little bit
further back there's a lot of you guys
know my love life back in second grade
knew it I know this story already does
not oh you don't
you're helping him back in second grade
I had a crush on like four girls in the
class
damn you know how that's like sometimes
you're just like I like this girl I like
this grunts Leia in second grade okay
baskin-robbins pip dude I actually found
out one of them liked me back so I
erased the other two out of my radar B's
it for ya I mean the other three and one
of those girls one of the things we used
to do all the time during recess if she
would have string cheese and she would
always string one and give me a piece in
stream one and give herself a piece Wow
and one day I don't know what happened I
don't know if spring break happen and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] fell in love with
someone else
but I remember a break happening like
Christmas and we we weren't together
anymore and I saw her by the palm tree
eating string cheese and she's supposed
to share with me and she did it and I
was like man [ __ ] water she drink
cheese's somebody else no I should was
just eating it by herself
[ __ ] it was over because she was eating
by herself no because you know we were
we were tightly with hold hands and we
would play house together and then now
I went to go talk to her name was Megan
and I'm like hey Megan and then she
would just ignore me
you know why you holding my hand for you
to go on Facebook and [ __ ] fine Megan
and be like yo I need to know cuz you
didn't give me any closure yeah what the
[ __ ] happened during spring babe yeah
very very simple it's like you are
really sticky you also smelled like [ __ ]
and you never washed your hands and I
found out you had a question on three
other girls yeah
something very simple when people never
think is their fault yeah fair play fair
play um question well who rushed I
didn't work out why why didn't know what
crush that didn't work out someone you
dated someone who dated dated yeah why
didn't work out English girl Katie
couldn't consume this River College
stinky feet all stinky feet whoa really
I can't stand bad smells so bad :
awesome and you guys were about to get
freaky and she takes her she literally
came over took off her [ __ ] shoes
because she was not in track [ __ ]
stunk up the whole place dunt and that's
a polish hot dog for you all right Joe
um what was my thing oh yeah okay so I
never thought this would have happened
but I was being over serviced so like
there is such a thing much say too much
[ __ ] too much pampering too much
everything like cuz yeah cuz what the
[ __ ] are you talking about it is man
it's it's excessive it's because the
person that I was dating she gets off on
taking care but it's it's it's it's
almost like having a mom that's too
[ __ ] buggy like joking like you you
hungry and I'm like nah are you sure I
could do this now are you even psych and
it's like everything in life what about
this what about that it's like yo I told
you I don't want a [ __ ] today and
it's like [ __ ] you already gave me five
it's like the chase is the big sometimes
you watch yeah go away alright yeah and
I never thought that there would be a
day where I'm like I actually think I
don't want to be pampered and taken care
of listen I like the chase because
eventually it gives me a [ __ ] like I
don't
like you don't have to work for it and
it just happens that's incredible
yeah but then [ __ ] genie what if what
if your what if there's but what if
you're coming powdered [ __ ] dust
powder yeah and then you're just done
and then it's like I'll go to the
grocery store I'll buy some hydrating
water rehydrates my [ __ ] body
it's exist talking about it's not just
those go to a [ __ ] lab and I'll beg
you know can you guys give me
intravenous fluids so that I can produce
more calm because I'm coming dust
because I [ __ ] love my girlfriends
it's like what a nice it's like what
it's a it's when a girl gives a nice guy
a chance when he finally gets a chance
right they start dating and he's
excessively still thirsty buying her all
kinds of [ __ ] he's going and she's like
[ __ ] dude it's too much it's [ __ ] way
too much yes you're right from God a
girl that's too much but from girl to
guy involving [ __ ] you lost me I
guess it's my turn
uh so I don't think this tips turn oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry we interrupted to
interrupt you don't like this supposed
to be a good friend
oh well for me that was this guy in
sixth grade back when I used to go to
Catholic school he was super cute his
name was Chris already like Kathleen
Chris yeah automatically CHCH yeah
whatever go ahead anyway so then uh I
guess he wasn't Mexican oh shut up
he was Mexican oh sure big Chris okay
who's Thomas yeah I'm Mexican Catholic
my brother's name is Christian sometimes
it's not Krystal that Christopher is
Christian you know they call him Chris
yeah because they're stupid anyway I get
involved in this so anyway so we were
dating or whatever in sixth grade for
but then but then his mom found out they
had a girlfriend and then he got in
trouble he said we can't date anymore so
oh damn biggest mistake I had a friend
named Chris Hernandez yeah I had a lot
of friends named Chris anyway so now
it's my turn
unbelievable enough so I'm gonna make a
move make your move battle between you
two who me and Steve I'll give it to you
hmm
they're nice your turn my turn to make a
move yeah let me see let me see them
what oh they're in there he's my card
see boom right back gotcha
okay Oh boom David all right David your
turn what do you want to do you can
interrogate make a move or pick a
[ __ ] move real quick [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] banned I'm gonna give
this to you real quick
oh really me but I think I knows all
right well I'm gonna give this to you
real quick well before we do anything
else so David did conclude the first
round and now Joe is gonna bring us into
the second round which he already kind
of did yeah and the only thing that you
guys can do in the second round is just
make a move so you can no longer
interrogate and you can no longer peek
so Joe already kicked it off tip what
would you like to do what you gonna do a
tear but did you see my [ __ ] heart
shatter to a million pieces there's so
many good times Steve what would you
like to do who are you making it make a
move I'm making it who's getting that
cold making a move dude oh sure Vanessa
Carlton yeah yeah I know it's your [ __ ]
you know I'm talking about
I'm still feeling Bart out okay are you
making a mistake
normally we play on you might get up
this is the move of the century to move
of the years it's alright o me where Z
I'm giving it to you he passes over that
Joe happy birthday
alright Davis you're the last one
straight to Joe so yeah yeah you not you
give one last card away right yep yep
make your last move give me that one cuz
whatever you gave me is gonna cancel
cancel out you can't see that I'll give
this to the puta over there me yeah you
heard of you that's so funny that's so
hilarious
only because it was over there not the
booth that part alright so that
concludes round one and round two rounds
one on the count of three we're all
gonna show our character cards are ready
one two three [ __ ] friendly fire
whiskey okay ready red team okay red
team review your car did you get any
cards from anyone
yes I already do what are you Oh tact oh
okay so red team right now is negative
one tip what did you get I got nothing
okay so moving on to me
I got who gave me this one pound right
there I knew it boom boom boom negative
- it's okay it's okay we got we're back
to negative three
yeah back so negative one oh we're back
down at negative 2 dang it oh you got
another one giving so why are you so
happy [ __ ] that's why yeah you hurt me
bro we're on the same team he's always
trying to hurt you either way the
objective of the game is to make her
feel bad it's called hurt Geo shady
dajun's all right so we're negative to
blue team
Joe what did you get ok I got a heal
from home I don't know you thought Joe
was telling lies but what I think is
that I'm the ultimate shady agent
because I like to sabotage my own team I
unlocked another level of the
Kickstarter ultra shame okay I got you
backstab the backstabber
oh so negative one these are at negative
one right now fart I [ __ ] us I was
gonna give it to you two it was between
you two yeah when I [ __ ] up oh sorry
on the same chain yeah I got the
butthole thing I thought it was a bit
freaking know he's like the shady shady
agent no Jew knows how sensitive my
butthole is oh right okay this is the
one I got one more car
[Music]
yes so that means blue team gone no
thanks to me yeah yeah well cuz are
stupid agent over there killed oh no
technically
see this is what happened see you guys
won and I also want because I heard her
mi [ __ ] okie full circle this is what
this game is supposed to do it tears up
your friends friendships apart so
definitely don't miss out on this
opportunity to lock in your game cruise
on over to the description box below
where we're gonna have the Kickstarter
link and definitely opt for the option
with the blue box this is a blue black
box back in black and gold it's a really
dope box it's exclusive to just you guys
who purchase it because after this
kickstart is over you're not gonna be
able to get that anymore
and like I was saying it comes with
exclusives not-safe-for-work stuff
because these were really really some
other tears come with and yes we are
gonna autograph that for you so who the
not safer work that must be great that's
so remember when you make the pledge
you're not donating you're pledging to
get your box secured so do it do it do
it do it and if we get 5,000 backers me
and drop the kiss and don't you want to
know when your friend lost their
virginity yeah oh yeah or me and David
get to wrestle naked know why naked dude
we could just as well just be in pain
why two types of pain okay there's a
voluntary me and Dave will get to
wrestle no I figured to what level five
thousand backers yeah if we get five
dollars and backwards
Russell please you guys make how much
your new Brussels 5001 5001 and we can
make it up and they have over 15,000
followers on just the shady agents
Instagram so if every one of you guys
has followed that back it we can get
10,000 backers and me and David will
wrestle naked we're gonna both take
viagra and we'll wrestle naked pretty
good
[Laughter]
[Music]